bonjour tu avais des aviez veille sa
merci de répondre à nos questions ce
matin sur rtl france londres et
bruxelles qui reprennent donc les
négociations en cette fin de semaine
qu'est ce qu'il faut en attendre les
pourparlers qui s'arrêtent qui repartent
ils s'arrêtent qui repartent
on ne voit pas la fin de ce feuilleton
breakbeat ça fait ça fait cinq ans qu'on
n'en voit pas la fin effectivement ce
qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut absolument
s'est trouvé un un deal parce
qu'effectivement si on ne trouve pas de
deal ça coûterait 30 3 milliards d'euros
on peu près à l'union européenne si on
trouve un accord
sas a divisé par deux au moins la
facture entre de taxation entre l'inde
et des changes pour entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne
après il faut se mettre dans la position
est dans la tête de barry johnson qui
est à un jour de poker un petit peu
comme comme donald trump qui aime bien à
dire que c'est fini que les discussions
sont terminées pour essayer d'en
accrocher et d'obtenir un peu plus de
michel barnier et l'union européenne
il faut il faut donc savoir être aussi
tacticien que lui dans dans ces
négociations mais je fais confiance à
michel varnier pour d'une part ne pas
qu'il y à un new deal parce que ce
serait dramatique pour la grande
bretagne comme pour nous parce
qu'effectivement o'neal on en parle de
plus en de plus en plus est ce que c'est
vraiment plausible ou bien un accord à
la dernière minute
pourrait-il arriver parce que pour le
moment on a l'impression que les deux
parties semblent camper sur leurs
positions au le moment il ya deux trois
points de blocage il ya le notamment le
point de blocage sur les pêches sur la
pêche et sur les autres pour soutenir
des de grande bretagne qui sont
effectivement un grès en jeu pour pour
les européens et pour la grande bretagne
et puis il ya comment nous rêverions à
l'avenir nous conflit quand il y aura
effectivement des différends commerciaux
entre la grande bretagne et l'union
européenne sur ces deux points il ya
encore des discussions et il n'y a pas
encore d'accord possible enfin pour nous
mon possible mais il nous reste il nous
reste une dizaine de jours et c'est pour
ça que depuis hier les européens sont à
londres pour négocier et terminer cette
phase de discussion qui sur ces deux
points ne sont pas non plus inextricable
on sait très bien que pour régler nos
différends
on peut trouver on peut trouver une
solution là où on risque de faire de
devoir faire des compromis c'est sur la
pêche jeux je crains qu électivement de
nos pêcheurs européens soient un peu
sacrifié sur l'autel de deux de ces
discussions
c'est pour pallier un divorce dur avec
bruxelles que les britanniques celle des
partenariats avec d'autres pays
illustration en ce matin avec la
signature entre lee stress et donc la
ministre du commerce extérieur
britannique et le chef de la diplomatie
japonaise d'un accord bilatéral et ce
alors même que les négociations post
break sites reprennent et semble quand
même s'enliser bien sûr c'est pour ces
pour compenser on l'a toujours dit que
la grande-bretagne et claude rich site
serait de toute façon pénalisé sur un
plan économique elle perdu des parts de
marché à la fluidité entre deux coups de
commerçants des biens de caen de butyle
grande bretagne vers l'union européenne
seront seront moins de vent et donc ils
ont lilo et cherche d'autres
partenariats à l'extérieur et avec le
japon avec lesquels ils ont de toute
façon des liens depuis depuis longtemps
et c'est tout à fait logique ça rentre
aussi dans le cadre de la partie de
poker que peu penaud on parle avec boris
johnson c'est à dire qui ils montrent
que lui aussi il a des cartes dans son
jeu
d'autres car jusqu'à maintenant ça veut
dire ça c'est un moyen de pression ça un
levier sur lequel il peut s'appuyer
boris johnson parce qu'il ya d'autres
accords post brixi qui sont en attente
avec deux pays les états unis
l'australie la nouvelle zélande
l'europe a de quoi avoir peur l'europe
c'est un moyen de pression sur sur les
sur les plus sûres sur ceux qui
négocient actuellement et notamment
michel barnier mais on voit bien que
c'est un c'est un rapport de force qu'il
aurait pu enclencher bien avant si si
c'était crédible
il ya effectivement les états unis mais
depuis regarder depuis que l'élection
américaine a eu lieu il n'a pas
finalement avancé beaucoup sur ses liens
avec la avec les états unis alors que
vous nous promettez des normes accord
historique
les termes étaient plus dithyrambique
les uns que les autres
d'un côté comme de l'autre de
l'atlantique et finalement aujourd'hui
il ya toujours rien entre entre le
président américain et bobby johnson
or on voit bien que donald trump
aujourd'hui très en difficulté dans sa
propre campagne
américaine risque de ne pas être réélu
et donc les négociations avec les
démocrates seront quand même beau
américains risquent d'être beaucoup plus
difficile est beaucoup plus complexe
parce que c'était pas du tout la même
livré la même approche
merci david xavier weiss et avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes l'auteur du livre co auteur du
livre l'europe et après aux éditions
bart jones